why is it so poofy because oh my god
looks like a dead body in there oh
on the last trip that i took to albania
me and florian's sister went wedding
dress shopping
the reason why i didn't tell darcy is
because i knew she wouldn't like it
because it's not her style or her taste
and
i didn't need to hear about it it's my
wedding dress
and i'm the one that has to wear it
all right this is it whoa
it was like a wave oh
isn't it beautiful
it's so sparkly it's exactly what i
wanted
okay check it out let me see how poofy
this really is
put it out don't put makeup on it all
right stacy
you're the one getting tanner on it
please
it's very couture i could tell but it's
a couture dress so
okay i understand if you want my opinion
it's the stacey dress
okay it's a pretty stacy's dress but
it's not really appropriate for
the kind of wedding that i would think
that you have here
well i don't think it really matters
it's a beautiful wedding dress and i
want to have beautiful photos
and feel like a princess on that day and
that's what i'm gonna do okay and i
think he wants to see me in a big
ballgown type dress because
in albania they they do that in albania
[Music]
i didn't really envision stacy wearing
that for
a connecticut wedding or a beach wedding
or whatever kind of wedding she was
thinking of having
it's just over the top and very poofy
and the thuff's being really well
endowed and short and a little stumpy
you should go wait miss piggy
you